It is our last day of design week.
Although designs never going
anywhere from this show.
Cause it is my happy place
but we want to send it off in a big way.
And we recently challenged
three social media design superstars
to take this dresser from basic to beautiful.
Take a look.
Hi, I'm Jenni Yolo from ice by DIY.
I renovate old houses
here in Milwaukee, Wisconsin with my husband
and document the whole process.
My favorite things are bold pink colors,
spending way too much time at thrift stores
and DIY decor.
Hi I am Carli Alves made by Carly,
a DIY and home renovations blog,
where I share my passion
for home decor and budget friendly DIYs.
I love creating spaces in my home
which I call pockets of pretty that
are classic and affordable.
And I love being able
to share inspiration and ideas along the way.
My name is Kate Arends.
I am the founder of Wit and delight,
which is a lifestyle brand
that empowers readers
to design a life well lived.
I'm so excited about this project.
I have all my supplies behind me.
I have chalk paint.
I have wallpaper, I have vintage looking handles.
I'm going to get started doing some sketches.
Just with what I know is coming.
My kids are going to help me
probably pick out the colors.
Put them all together
to give this basic dresser a makeover
So let's get started.
Here goes nothing.
(soft music)
I have just been informed that there is
a surprise waiting for us
from the Drew Barrymore show.
So I'm gonna go grab that
and I'm gonna open it in front of you.
Oh, yellow paint.
All right. So yellow, yellow, red and pink.
(soft music)
(audience claps)
That is so brilliant.
The kids hand print.
I cannot wait to see these finished dressers.
So let's meet our designers.
Please know that
I am meeting personal rock stars
because that's what designers are for me.
Kate Arends, Carli, Alves, and Jenni Yolo.
(audience claps)
I am so excited to meet you guys.
I just have to tell you
that I'm such a fan girl.
Thank you for all that you do and guide
and influence everyone out there
to make life prettier,
to make every day better.
So Kate, will you show us your dresser
and how you approached the challenge?
Teach us
So dressers right behind me,
I miss going to flea markets.
So I wanted to bring a little bit
of that quirky essence into this dresser.
I had some left beets and some really sweet knobs
and just felt that I could add a little bit
of little details to this,
you know, simple dresser
and you know, bring some quirk to it.
I mean, I feel kind of bad
that we threw you a curve ball
of the yellow in this challenge.
And yet I'm so glad that we did
because I love this pink trim
because I don't often see trim
in the actual drawer.
It's always on the dresser itself.
That is brilliant.
I also love that you combine two different knobs.
I feel like people would be very scared of that
but making that top drawer,
its own little entity.
Brilliant. I love it.
I love it.
(audience claps)
I absolutely am in awe.
I always am learning stuff
and this is what's so exciting.
Trim on the drawer itself.
Okay. Carly, you deconstructed
and then reconstructed your dresser.
Wow. Okay. May we see it?
How did it come out?
Teach us.
So I truly believe that
necessity is the mother of invention
and that's kind of what starts
all of my creative projects.
And when I received the dresser, I said
I need something in my dining room
to hold my liquor.
(audience laughs)
So I took the legs off.
I decided to use wooden dowels
to kind of elevate it
and it truly elevated the whole entire piece.
I love the way it came out.
I am flabbergasted right now.
Because you, I think are showing people
the mentality of what you see
is not necessarily what it needs to be.
And that is so liberating.
And so freeing, it really does sometimes
take someone else to open our own eyes.
And your execution is beautiful.
I love what mechanism did you put in there?
May I ask to hold the glasses upside down?
Like what really reminds us
of being at a restaurant?
Yeah. So you can buy
these little wooden wine glass hole.
It's actually a wine glass holder
that you just screw in right to the top.
It was super easy.
Okay. I also just being told it's easy
and doable is what gets people out of
their fear mode of,
Oh, I could never do that.
I cannot thank you enough.
That was mind blowing.
Okay. Jenny, it's now your turn to show us your
dresser and walk us through your design choices.
Teach us.
Yeah, my dresser is right behind me.
I love using chalk paint mostly
because you don't have to do much prep
no sanding or priming.
And I really wanted it to have this
rich egg plant color that kind of mimics
the bathroom right next to it.
Cause I'm gonna use this as a linen closet.
And then I wanted to add some antique vintage
looking handles and gilded legs
with some gold paint
just to make it look really rich
and then added a little wallpaper
to the inside for a pop of pattern
I want to focus on
what you did around the dresser as well
because you made the dresser,
this neutral gorgeous colored star,
but how you styled it changed everything.
The picture frame,
that's sort of an old antique art
and a sort of beautiful floral dried branchy look
and the candles,
you really turn this up on its head
and I'm so impressed. I really am.
You created a really beautiful sort of
shaker antique moment.
I love it.
Thanks. This corner
is definitely kind of Instagram famous.
It's had many different versions
and I just love styling it.
It's just the legs are beautiful too
Well. And you guys are very you know
social media famous
and I'm so honored that you would come
on this show and this was just so much fun.
Thank you so much for being here.
And if you want to see even more
design ideas from Kate Carly and Jenny
go to our website
where we will be celebrating them
on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
(Soft music)